in the decade of the 1930s movie opens
by making me listen to a stupid little
kid read a comic book I think I would
rather just read the words on screen in
five minutes at 40 seconds of opening
credits the panic isn't it just like
Marlon Brando to deliberately
mispronounce Krypton movie spends its
first 10 minutes setting up the villains
for the sequel instead of actually
starting the story jor-el imprisoned Zod
and the others in a Listerine breath
strip well you are one of Krypton's
greatest scientists
is he a scientist or a prosecutor I tell
you a Krypton wait so everyone in this
movie mispronounces Krypton um you can
totally see the curtain behind this
planetary explosion the early history of
our universe jor-el provides several
years worth of educational lessons for
Superman's flight to earth but fails to
give him even one thing granola bar or
fruit roll-up you know who would love a
good super long origin story no one no
often yeah orphans are hilarious geez
look at the size of Lana's pom-poms a
lot of work what are you talking about
it just fixed this a school Brad knocks
over all the equipment Clark stacked
including a bench but Clark and Lana
didn't hear a thing even though they're
5 feet away Superman is addictive
football's Clark runs like a girl a
really really fast girl this little girl
turns into the 30 year old Lois Lane in
12 years
so wait pas can't never fix that flat
tire on the truck he was driving when he
found Clark Cheerios product placement
proudly facing the audience in this shot
and can't get enough of the spotlight as
it magically turns around to face eager
cereal buyers in this shot you can see
the director of this movie in the
reflection of the revolving door Clark
gets stuck trying to go through the same
section of the revolving door as Louis
so he waits for the next partition but
is in the same one as Lois in the next
shot doesn't sticking the gun out kind
of negate the fact that you're hiding I
guess Superman's secret identity is
still safe who's going to believe this
pimp in his tuhoe's anyway
well someone needs a sandwich know what
the new hearing kid needs like something
FUBU
like a big Bluebird yeah it's the 70s
but the news of Superman saving Louis
and the helicopter somehow didn't make
it to the police station even though
there were hundreds of witnesses and
news crews covering the event not to
mention other cops
Superman's head is way too large for his
body in the shot I see a bobble head
don't look just fly good thing you hired
that co-pilot based on his lack of
curiosity how does this hologram thing
work
did jor-el spend most of his time
recording every possible answer to his
son's questions does a dead jor-el just
work like a way better version of Siri
hello he flew all the way from
metropolis to New York City given the
exact location of the galaxy that he
mentions Superman never told Lois
where's galaxy was from the planet
Krypton exploded and went into outer
space it is reasonable to assume that
some of those particles of debris
drifted to earth uh no it's not a
meteorite found in Addis Ababa where
does it say this meteorite came from
Krypton the level of specific
radioactivity is so high to anyone from
the planet Krypton this substance is
lethal how do you know it's radioactive
two people from Krypton who told you
that
well I suggest vigorous chest massage
that didn't work
mount the mountain yes sir the US
military on an important rocket delivery
schedule decide there's time to sexually
assault the supposedly dead or
unconscious Eve but she's one of the bad
guys and it's the 70s so I guess it's
okay absolutely everyone in this convoy
has to run to talk to Lex Luthor and not
one person feels the need to guard or
watch the rock at the entire time
what lex luthor's security camera feed
switch from the angle of Superman to a
super close up of the gun nozzle why
does he even have a camera set up to
record this the military decides there's
no need to recheck the coordinates of
the rocket before it's launched even you
and your great speed couldn't stop both
Lex's Superman can't possibly stop two
missiles going in opposite directions
into two different coasts in time and
Superman seems to agree with him which
is odd when that whole going around the
planet a hundred times in a couple
minutes thing comes up so let's get this
timeline straight shall we Lex Otis and
Eve are in Colorado to sabotage the
rocket while Lois and Jimmy Olsen are
checking out a seemingly unrelated land
fraud story we're told that a meteorite
was stolen from a museum in Addis Ababa
the previous night which we know Lex is
responsible for then Lex talks to
Superman through some doggie er
frequency and he goes down to the
underbelly of Metropolis where Lex is
waiting in order to expose Superman to
the Kryptonite Lex's bumbling henchmen
have made the day-long flight from
Ethiopia to Colorado by next morning and
from Colorado to New York metropolis in
like two minutes did a child draw the
United States radar map somehow Megatron
is not unleashed when the Hoover Dam is
destroyed
this would cause human beings to fall
off the earth and it definitely wouldn't
turn back time Superman takes lexan Otis
Street to jail without due process gal J
bye buddy hope you find your dad thanks
mr. Narwhal
you